miles de palestinos se congregaron para
lamentar la muerte de dos jóvenes cerca
de la ciudad de yening en el norte de
las discordania ocupada
[Música]
samer hushillegi fue adabet Fueron
impactados por disparos del ejército
israelí en medio de un violento
enfrentamiento con la población local
que protestaba por la demolición de las
casas de dos palestinos acusados de
matar a un soldado israelí en septiembre
del año pasado
los propietarios de las casas demolidas
recuerdan a las víctimas como Héroes de
la resistencia Palestina estos casas
Ahora son solo un montón de piedras un
símbolo de la fuerza de nuestros hijos y
su fuerza de asalto y la fuerza de su
determinación
la política que implementa la ocupación
no trajeron resultado definitivamente no
el resultado que esperan no quebrarán
nuestro espíritu y no nos van a quebrar
al contrario eso hará que la gente sea
más decidida y firme usted
el Ministerio de salud de Palestina
confirmó que una de las víctimas
pertenecía a las brigadas de los
mártires de alaxa facción armada del
Movimiento Político fata que gobierna en
Jordania y considerada como organización
terrorista por Israel sin embargo la
organización yihadista jamás activa en
la franja de gaza aseguró que uno de los
jóvenes muertos pertenecía al grupo
desde la primavera pasada el ejército
israelí ha estado realizando incursiones
en territorio palestino casi a diario
incursiones que terminan en violencia y
disturbios tan solo el año pasado 150
palestinos murieron en el contexto de
las redadas israelíes convirtiéndose el
2022 en el año más violento en
cisjordania desde 2006
tras el reciente regreso al poder de
bellaw en Israel las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos temen una escalada de
la violencia
netanyahu conformó Un gobierno
ultranacionalista asociado con el
sionismo y ha expresado públicamente que
desea expandir los asentamientos
israelíes en